you got fired slash left that job uh and
that took you to the the job that would
be the lowest point yeah
because it was a huge downgrade and hey
I went from getting like I think at the
casino because I worked so much overtime
I was getting like 22.50 an hour on all
my overtime Fifth and this was back in
2008 2009 as like a college student like
it's amazing pay
um the I had benefits like everything
was good and then the carpet cleaning
was like I was probably getting my
paycheck like every other week was maybe
1500 bucks or a thousand dollars and I'm
working like 13 day stretches like I
have every other Sunday off and it's so
many hours like I have to show up at the
shop at like seven or six and then I go
home at like eight or nine depending on
when my jobs are throughout the day are
you doing uh businesses or residential
or what are you doing everything
everything are you working for a company
that's covering or you do okay so like
there's a schedule thing you have to go
to it and so on yeah but so like this is
why the schedule would suck because
sometimes I'd show up at I I think we
had to be in the shop at I think it was
7 A.M we show up at the shop at 7 A.M
first job might be at eight or nine but
that job might be like a one hour job so
I might show up at 7am and have a drive
from 8 30 to 9 30. then my next job
might not be from until like say 11. so
from 8 30 9 30 I'll do one job and then
I've got to drop from like 11 to 12 or
something then I might have like a
decent job from like five to eight
but like my whole day is destroyed
and I'm I'm doing like three smallish
jobs so I'm getting like 30 bucks maybe
for being in the shop or you know my job
for like 10 or 11 hours and it's just
like horrible so here's somebody that
seems to be extremely good at thinking
and conversation and so have a bit of an
ego perhaps uh in in both the negative
and the positive sense of that word was
there some aspect of working a
McDonald's
and then working at the casino and
working for the uh as a carpet cleaner
that was humbling no never
um I had a the ego burned bright through
it all the well or no yeah you can push
back on the ego yeah no I understand I
totally get what you mean um I had a
really close friend growing up whose
name was Chris and I think we probably
met when he was we were like four or
five I think he lived behind me and I
grew up with him and I'd always been
kind of an outsider to the world that I
was in once I got to high school for
sure because all of those kids were
incredibly wealthy you know Corvettes
and Mustangs when they turned 16. it was
a prep school and I was doing the they
had like a work study program there
where you could stay after school from 2
30 to 5 every day to kind of like work
to pay for your tuition so I've been
working like throughout all of high
school I got another job at McDonald's
when I was 18 worked at the casino like
I'd always been doing that kind of work
I never really viewed it as like beneath
me or anything it's not like I don't
have like a family of doctors or lawyers
or anything and then me and my other
friend uh Chris guy we'd always make fun
of everybody else for being kind of like
uh you know like preppy kids and
everything so so there was a there's
some pride to that sort of hard work
yeah I guess a little bit yeah because
you know looking especially my dad like
the solution to every problem was just
throw more hours of work at it basically
so that was always my yeah go-to and I
never am what was psychologically the
low point
I think psychologically the low point
was that um as I'm doing this carpet
cleaning job uh driving around my city
there's like this feeling of
I guess for a lot of people it's
probably college but there's a feeling
when you're in high school that
everything is like so exciting and the
whole world is kind of in front of you
and there are a trillion trillion
different branching Paths of
possibilities and you know even through
high school you're thinking like am I
going to be a doctor or a lawyer or can
I join the MBA or can I do this or that
there's all these things in front of you
and when I I especially felt it when I
was doing these carpet cleaning jobs and
um
I think it was in the fall I'd be
outside some of these houses and I just
kind of look around and I'd recognize a
lot of these neighborhoods that I drive
around with friends in or I'd you know
be walking through I do I ran cross
country some of them I'd be running
through these neighborhoods and it was
just kind of like this feeling of
looking around and it was like
when I was here in the past this was
like kind of like a transitionary phase
of my life where I'm doing this and it's
so fun and exciting and then I'm going
to move on to something else and it's
gonna be fun and exciting and awesome
and then like you know two years later
my whole life has collapsed like I'm in
a house that I can't afford anymore my
ex that I hate is pregnant with my kid
and I have no money I've got no upward
Mobility I failed College I my job is
horrible like just every single out like
this is like my all of those the wave
function had collapsed into one thing
and that one thing was the worst thing
that it could have possibly been at the
time for me yeah like everything was
gone and horrible so yeah that was the
feeling ahead of the time do you ever
gone to play suicide I thought about
thinking about it but I've just never
been that kind of person so
I mean basically as a way to escape from
the hardship something that I'm so
incredibly lucky I don't know why or how
I'm just gonna chalk it up to biology
I've always had really high mental
Baseline I've like depression and all of
that there have been a few short stints
I've dealt with it past 30 because I did
a lot of drugs but um other than that my
mental Baseline is just so high and even
in the carpet cleaning days
um like if you man the videos might
still be there I think on my old YouTube
channel channel where I'll be like
playing Starcraft when I first started
getting into streaming and I'll be
calling up customers like this is Steve
from Guaranteed Clean we had to move
your job back one hour is it okay if I
show up instead of 2 30 and then I hang
up it's like all right guys we got three
more games and it's like let's go like
stuff like that so my Baseline has
always been like really high for mental
function so even in the low Point
there's that you had strength is there
is there anything you can give by way of
advice from people that for home to wave
function collapses as it does for many
of us like holy [ __ ] the the world is
not full of opportunity and you're kind
of a failure like I've I've been there
yeah I don't know the it's rough because
like I usually ask for compassion from
people that I have it better off because
like once you're down there like the
only reason I say I got lucky but it
wasn't even really lucky like or it was
lucky but it was more lucky I wasn't
just lucky that I got into streaming it
was lucky that I was into computers at
an early age it was lucky that I played
video games at an early age it was lucky
that all the tech came up at exactly
that right point in time
um like I was a pretty smart guy but it
was definitely a preparation meets
opportunity and that opportunity was
like at the exact precise moment of my
life if anything had gone differently
then I would just be cleaning carpets
today so so in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
this is like one out of like there's
many many Stevens that are just still
carpet cleaning and they're full of pain
and resentment yeah the the one piece of
advice that I give I hate that I have to
push back against all these crypto Bros
and everybody online for decently
intelligent people that are successful
I've never heard anybody give a
contradiction of this maybe you will you
can tell me if you disagree
I always look at kids in high school and
I'm like just try a little bit harder
like 30 minutes a night if you don't
study just do 30 minutes just do a
little bit more
um it is you're laying the foundation
for the rest of your life and you can't
appreciate it in high school and college
but oh my god when you get out
everything in your life is so much
easier you have probably more
responsibility over the direction of
your life when you're like 13 14 years
old than you ever will once you're like
25 and older because this is like when
you're determining the foundations that
everything's gonna build up yeah 100 so
first of all it does seem that
the liberating aspect of being young is
like anything you learn
so working hard at learning something
will pay off in like non-linear ways
like you said with video games I feel
like so like people who are like I hate
school all right well fine but find
something
where you're challenging yourself you're
growing you're learning you're learning
a skill you're learning about a thing
of course you know you could push back
and say well there's some trajectories
that might not be productive like if you
spend the entirety of your teen years
playing I don't know League of Legends
game you have love and hate relationship
with no just a hate and hate
relationship okay well we'll talk about
I think you have a lovely relationship
with hate in general we'll just hit and
love okay we'll we'll try to
decomplexify that one uh I think in
general just investing yourself fully
with passion it really does pay off but
that said also School
I feel like
doesn't get enough credit like High
School in particular middle school and
high school because it's general
education
if
I I think if you if you're especially if
you're lucky to have good teachers but
honestly I haven't mostly the textbooks
themselves were good teachers it's a one
chance in life you have to really
explore a subject [ __ ] Grace like
getting good grades
is at tension I would say with actual
learning that is true but just get a
biology textbook and to explore ideas in
biology and allowing yourself to be
um inspired by the beauty of it
yeah I don't know I I think that really
really pays off and you never get a
chance to do that again and maybe not
even textbooks like reading straight up
reading I think I think if you read this
is a one time in life you get a chance
to read
really read like read a book a day read
you you could really invest you can
really grow by reading I mean you know I
must all those guys talk about it like
it's very very rare that you meet like a
dumb person who reads a lot I don't know
if that's ever happened in my life yeah
dumb or not successful and this and the
cool thing is it seems like the reading
this like investment the reading you do
early on in high school pays off way
more than the reading you do later uh so
like the the really influential reading
is uh uh is it did during those high
school years because you're basically
learning from others the mistakes
they've made the solutions to problems
you're basically learning the shortcuts
to life
like whatever the hell you want to do
music read from the best people uh that
the music theory like learn music theory
learn uh read biographies about jazz
musicians Blues musicians see their like
see all the mistakes see what they did
see the shortcuts if you want to do
podcasting read about other podcasts if
you want to do stream and read about
other streamers physicists and so on and
I feel like you figure out all the
mistakes and you get the shortcut
through life because most people show up
to college without having done that and
now you get a chance to shortcut your
way past them yeah 100 I'm I'm gonna but
nobody really teaches you that they're
like go to school
this from this time to that time that
you're shut up you this is just what you
do eat your broccoli